[Music]
to visualize the pdb structure for hhb
in molestar first open the structure
summary page
just clicking on this 3d view will open
the molestar page
this is your 3d canvas i can just
use the mouse in the 3d canvas to move
things around
you can see four protein chains shown
here in four different colors
on the top the sequence panel gives you
access to the sequence of all polymers
and other contents in the structure so
in this case
there are the two hemoglobin entities
and if i select one entity there are two
copies so chain a chain c
and then other than that there is the
heme group phosphate and
waters this panel is to
navigate and select and show
different components so for example i
can hide the polymer show the polymer
let's hide the waters for simplicity
sake
[Music]
so we are trying to investigate the heme
group
bound to chain a the heme group here
i could just click on this or
i could find the heme groups here
they are a b c d four heme groups are
here so i'm selecting chain a
and if i click on that i get to
explore the environment around the heme
and so once you're here you can mouse
over the residues shown
and see this histidine
87 is forming a coordinate bond with the
iron in the heme
and there's another histidine here but
that's the distal histidine
for practice try to find the histidine
that coordinates the heme bound to chain
b now that we've explored the
neighborhood of a ligand
we want to look at a particular amino
acid residue in a chain
and see how it is interacting in chain c
c terminal residue this arginine 141
how is it interacting with whatever is
in the neighborhood
this is sort of an example of a
situation when
you're looking at a mutant and you're
trying to understand
how the interactions of that particular
residue is different
in the native versus mutant condition so
the way i would go about this
is i would go to
chain c
by selecting the entity one and chain c
so now i'm looking at chain c sequence
if i click on this
arginine this purple colored arginine
is the one in question so notice
this arginine is interacting with
this aspartate in chain a
it is interacting with some waters
it is also close to
this particular tyrosine from chain b
but it's not a direct interaction it is
via this
aspartate what is displayed here are
just these
hydrogen bonding interactions but you
can change
the so ionic interactions are not shown
here for example so i turn that on
and notice this arginine to aspartate
there is
an ionic bond you can turn
on and off these various options and
play with it
and see what you find